[electronic music]
>>Ian: Are we unmuted?
OK.
Now we are.
Good afternoon.
OK, welcome to--.
>>Dan: Oh, sorry.
[laughs]
>>Ian: Welcome to the Friday Review of Games
everyone.
I, as always, am Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Dan: And I am Dan Galpin.
>>Ian: And I have a very special present for
Dan today.
Today we are drinking, say it.
>>Dan: Oh, it's a Cuve di Chaque Auban, I
would say.
Maybe.
>>Ian: We'll go with that.
That sounds good.
>>Dan: Sounds close enough.
It might be Flemish, though.
It might have time--.
>>Ian: Ask Reto.
He's foreign.
[Dan laughs]
>>Reto: I am foreign.
>>Dan: Exactly.
How do we pronounce this?
>>Reto: It's Cuve di Chaque Auban.
>>Dan: Yes, I agree.
OK.
>>Ian: All right.
Do we get the Reto-cam?
Reto-cam.
>>Reto: Oh, Reto-cam's broken.
>>Dan: Oh, fail on the Reto-cam.
>>Ian: Oh, dammit.
All right.
>>Reto: I'm just a black void.
>>Dan: That's good because next week, we can
suck less and we can get the Reto-cam working.
>>Ian: There we go.
>>Dan: All right.
>>Ian: So, I gotta say something about this
beer because in, I don't want to like.
Here, you can have the open one.
>>Reto: Cuve di Chaque Auban.
>>Ian: Oh, nice.
>>Dan: Excellent.
>>Ian: Reto-cam.
>>Dan: Reto-cam.
Yeah.
>>Ian: Awesome.
OK.
>>Dan: You can just see just a little bit
of Big Pete in the background.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Indeed.
So, the thing about this beer, it's sour Flemish
ale.
Flemish sour red ale.
It is, it apparently has a cascade of beautiful
complex flavors, oak barrel aging for 18 months,
etc., etc.
>>Dan: Vanilla.
It's all about the vanilla note and sourness.
>>Ian: Actually, this is really, really sour
beer.
This is like, I've had sour beers before and
they were like, they were like lemonade or
something.
This is the warheads of beer.
This is, yeah.
>>Dan: This is, but it also has such a delicate
and complicated flavor.
I think of it like a champagne almost.
Even a whiskey of beer.
Except that it isn't, it doesn't taste anything
like whiskey.
>>Ian: It's extremely, no, no.
Yeah.
>>Dan: It's complicated.
It's just that whiskey is complicated.
>>Ian: Yeah, it's a very, very complicated
flavor.
>>Dan: Fine wine.
>>Ian: Yeah, I've had that--.
>>Reto: And I would say it's kind of like
a wine.
I would agree.
>>Dan: Yeah, yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
It's complex like that.
All right.
>>Dan: Thank you.
>>Ian: So, if you happen to watch the Friday
App Clinic last hour, you'll notice that I
was there along with Reto because I'm a big
proponent of podcast apps.
I've never found one that I liked.
Still haven't, but hopefully, we planted some
seeds.
You know what I'm looking for now.
Again, my 20 dollars are yours.
You wanna do a kickstarter?
I'll give you a hundred bucks.
Of course you'll have to give me something
for it.
>>Dan: Well, yeah.
Absolutely.
>>Ian: I would totally go for a transport
control that doesn't suck.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: And something that always plays whatever
is buffered up instead of failing randomly
because my internet went away.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: If that was like your hundred dollar
kick starter offer, I would totally go for
that.
All right.
Anyway.
>>Dan: All right.
>>Ian: So, the point that I'm making is I
played with podcast apps.
Dan played with games.
So, I'm just gonna sit back here and let him
advertise EA.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, I just wanted to say that I am absolutely
not wearing this because of any other reason
other than the fact that EA gave it to me
this week.
And it just happens to be that we're doing
sports today.
So, I figured wearing EA is part of it.
>>Ian: Bingo.
>>Dan: And we are not doing any EA titles
because none were nominated.
Not that they're not good titles.
I actually, I really like both soccer and
football, but we are here to look at games
people nominated on the moderator page.
And we have a very eclectic set of games.
And, of course, the Olympics are still technically
going on.
So,--.
>>Ian: But we don't know it because we don't
have cable subscriptions and all we get here
is NBC.
>>Dan: Yeah, and we do have a lot of YouTube
live streams going out there that is actually
how I have caught all of my Olympics that
I've seen this year is on YouTube.
Any of you YouTube folks that made that happen.
And let's talk about what we have today.
We've got a really wide variety of games.
We have everything from what I would call
simple, shoot, where they replicate one mechanic
game really well to actually, at the end we
actually even have a Olympic-style old summer
games style remix game.
>>Ian: Nice.
>>Dan: Cool, but--.
>>Ian: I played that for hours in junior high.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
This one has touch controls and it's pretty
cool.
A lot of these games need some work, but it
was great to see such a wide variety of stuff.
I was expecting golf games and soccer games
and we didn't get any of those.
So, no football games at all.
>>Ian: No.
>>Dan: No, no.
We, so we've got a couple of varied--.
>>Ian: Which is weird.
Do you think it's just that football games
on Android suck?
'Cause it feels like, you feel like that would
be really good for football games.
>>Dan: Yeah, we used to make, exactly.
Football Madness is great and so is the Game
Off title, Real Football or whatever.
They're both really good.
They get good ratings.
And soccer, very similar.
We've got three great soccer titles actually
on Android.
So, I'm not quite sure why, but I think people
wanted to play with other stuff.
We did actually, we sort of have a soccer
title in Neymar Game, which is awesome if
you are a fan.
And if you are a fan of football, of course
you are a fan of Neymar.
I'm probably pronouncing it wrong.
Is it Neymar?
Or, I don't know.
I'm terrible at names.
All right.
So, let's start off with the first one.
This is Stardunk.
It's kind of an interesting game because it
actually is a game, it's a multi-player game.
And you challenge random people.
Ooh, nice.
Points.
Free starpoints.
Interesting.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: All right.
Play online.
Why, yes.
I have logged into OpenFeint for you.
Not that I'm a huge fan of OpenFeint.
And, but anyways, the goal of this is to shoot
baskets.
And I first thought that actually, the gravity
of said planet would affect this, but it doesn't
as far as I can tell.
>>Ian: Well, that's boring.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's--.
However, it's fun.
It's fun to see a fun presentation of all
of this.
And it actually, there are, there actually
are three basketball games that we have that
all have the same shot mechanic.
This one just takes it out and to the farthest
crazy extent with the real time network challenge
here.
I really suck at this.
I'm sorry.
But--.
>>Ian: Yeah, I was gonna say, with the amount
of hints that you get with this, it seems
like you should be doing better.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Yeah.
The, especially since, in theory, I've played
it before we actually got on the air here.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: But you also, there's, you are, actually,
one of the goals is you want to hit all four
of the backboard pieces there.
That turns you into this fiery mode, which
I'll try to show you here.
Oh, I missed again.
>>Ian: So close.
>>Dan: I know.
Now I'm actually hitting baskets, trying to
hit the backboard.
Come on, I only have 52 seconds.
>>Ian: No, that's not gonna happen.
>>Dan: Yeah, I know.
>>Ian: Oh, come on.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
I'm just totally sucking.
Yes, finally.
>>Ian: There you go.
>>Dan: All right.
Now we're in like, in like flame happy mode
here on the baskets.
We're doing swish--.
Anyways.
So this is actually a pretty fun game.
Some general comments of it, we do see that,
I would like to see some higher resolution
art work for this, the static art work.
The font is definitely bleary here on the
Transformer Prime.
That's one of the very, the number font here
at the bottom.
And that's--.
>>Ian: I think that's intentional.
I think that's actually got a, 'cause look
at the number font on the top.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
But it's still, it's a combination of both
blur and--.
I mean, there is definitely something.
>>Ian: Well, I think that, yeah.
There's a little bit of bloom on it.
>>Dan: Bloom on it.
But I would still like to see a little higher
res, definitely with some of the text.
But overall, the presentation looks really
nice in this category of games.
It's good.
The back key is actually handled quite reasonably
here.
And you can see I go right back into my session
here where we get to see, oh, here at the
end where I rank with the rest of the world.
And there we are.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: So--.
>>Ian: That's not bad.
That screen is a little busy.
But the information is good.
>>Dan: Yeah, and I think part of this is also,
you'll see there's some places in which text
overlaps and stuff like that.
It's some little details here.
Again, we got really blurry looking icons.
>>Ian: I love how they have OpenFeint, yeah.
A blurry OpenFeint and Haze app and Twitter
and Facebook.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: And whatever App Sign is.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Is that a new thing?
Is that something the kids are doing that
I just don't even know about?
>>Dan: Yes, maybe share over email.
Yeah, it's over email.
So, interesting.
>>Ian: Woah.
>>Dan: I know.
>>Ian: That's sad.
>>Dan: Using the share intent.
I know.
They should really think about using a share
intent there at that point.
So, I would definitely comment on that.
Yeah.
It's nice to just not have the OpenFeint menu.
The problem with not having a menu key in
OpenFeint is there is no way for me to change
my profile.
So, I am forever Player one eight five four
seven four zero zero seven three.
Thank you OpenFeint for not having a button
to do anything in my settings.
>>Ian: It's weird that in a year, they haven't
changed that.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
I can't-- so anyways.
Normally, we need a menu key and actually,
in order to actually go in and make those
changes.
So, I'm awesome to see this game actually
is properly supporting Honeycomb in ICS without
having any kind of compatibility.
But with OpenFeint, it totally sucks.
So, OpenFeint, fix your problem.
Please.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: All right.
I just don't like--.
>>Ian: You just don't like fun.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's trying.
I actually would have.
I wanted to change it my real profile, but
it did not actually work.
So that was Stardunk and yeah.
It's fun, but I definitely want to see a little
bit, just a little bit of refinement there.
But other than that, I was pretty happy with
that game.
I thought it was really cool, a really cool
example of doing network play and doing a
tournament.
This has actually become really common.
This anonymous tournament with a whole bunch
of people all playing against a single timed
mode.
I would like to see some sort of reverse interaction
actually.
I think and all of that.
So, I'm going in the next game right now,
which is Ninja Volleyball.
And one of the things that you can tell here--Ninja
Volley--is that I'm right into the game and
it takes me into the last menu that I was
in, which is cool.
It's a little bit, actually, strange enough
jarring.
If I actually back out of the game, the expectation
is when I come back in, I'm actually going
to probably be at the same place rather than
back to where I was.
So, that's an interesting--.
>>Ian: What do you mean?
The same place, as in like, not where you
were?
>>Dan: As in not where I am.
See, I'm back at settings.
I don't know.
It's kind of interesting.
This has actually been customized.
Again, this is just from a UI perspective.
I just wanted to see, while this does definitely
work, it just, it would be cool to make it
a little clear what this interface is actually
doing.
This is hair.
And you figure out pretty well how to different
hair customizations and different colors.
>>Ian: It is weird that it's just numbers,
though.
I mean, I like--
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: that's an odd UI.
It looks like a debug UI.
>>Dan: It does, actually.
It looks like we're testing it.
And so, but it's really awesome.
You can create all sorts of different cool
customizations for your team.
The characters look good.
I want high res art work, but in fact, high
res font, especially.
I mean, as I said,--.
>>Ian: If you don't mind me saying something
about the font.
I know we were wrong last week when we dissed
on the Real Racing guy, not Real Racing, or
the Tiny Racing guy for using comic sans.
He was actually using just a font that ripped
off comic sans.
>>Dan: Correct, yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Which is just like yeah.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: It's like, "No, I'm not drinking Colt
45.
I'm drinking a cheaper version that tries
to be Colt 45."
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: Sure.
Anyway, I'm just gonna say this font, it looks
kinda like comic sans.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It definitely, definitely, definitely is not
comic sans.
>>Ian: It's not comic sans.
>>Dan: I see what they were trying to do.
>>Ian: It looks like an unholy union between
papyrus and comic sans.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It actually does remind me of that papyrus
quite a lot.
The main thing, I would say, is they're trying
to keep a ninja feel here.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: But this is not getting it, this particular
font.
Also, these are just bitmaps.
So I'd definitely like to see some really
cool work done on this.
>>Ian: The truth is, I think there should
just be a rule of--.
Oh, yeah.
>>Dan: That's much better.
I'd like to see everything use the font that
says "Best used in Bluetooth multi-player
coming soon."
>>Ian: There you go.
I think that is papyrus.
But papyrus stopped being exciting after [corrotica],
basically.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: My rule of thumb is in a game, do not
use a font that comes free with Microsoft
Word.
It just, it's just the wrong idea.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
All right.
So, we've got a lot of different options here.
There's Bluetooth player coming soon.
But there is--.
>>Ian: Let's get into the game.
>>Dan: Let's get into the game.
So, once again, again, this is just really
nicely imaginative game play here.
And when you actually get into playing the
game, what you actually have to do is touch
the ball with your hand.
And because you're ninjas, you move silently
and quickly to the spot where the ball is,
which is why I say it's volleyball.
>>Ian: Sweet.
>>Dan: So I love this.
>>Ian: So you don't need any animation at
all.
>>Dan: Exactly.
And I love--.
>>Ian: That is awesome.
>>Dan: I love the concept behind the--I just
died.
I love the concept behind the game.
>>Ian: How can you die?
You're a ninja.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
Well, just because I'm a ninja, doesn't mean
I can catch things correctly.
>>Ian: You're not a very good ninja, are you?
>>Dan: I'm a suck ninja.
Fourth touch.
Touch to continue.
See.
That was an interesting one, too.
Popping up a toast in the middle of your game
play, generally not a-- to transmit information.
Better than popping up a dialogue, but I'd
love to see it actually--.
>>Ian: Well, again, and I think actually the
developer of this game corresponded a little
bit with some of the critics on our moderator
page saying that they do actually have a lot
more to go.
This is, this is sort of an alpha quality
game, right?
>>Dan: And I'm totally impressed with what
they've done with it.
Honestly, the game is fun.
It plays well.
It actually uses gestures.
You don't just tap.
You actually, as you tap and then you can
actually fling with the gestures.
>>Ian: Very, very cool.
>>Dan: I definitely think some more tutorials.
Where you can see, they're actually doing
a lot of things right already.
They're using lights out mode in the game.
It actually navigates quite reasonably when
you're inside the game.
They're using libgdx.
>>Ian: Just need a little bit better assets
for the tablets.
Let's face it.
These just aren't good 720p assets.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Exactly.
They're, but it really a great start.
And you see the back key actually does do
something reasonable.
Here we are, back on our main menu and then
we are back out.
Kind of like you'd expect.
So, very nice game.
>>Ian: Not bad at all.
>>Dan: Good job, Ninja Volley guys.
And yeah, just keep going with that.
The next one was really, really interesting.
This was Basketball Lite and this is a game,
actually, that we looked at ages and ages
ago.
It's like, this is an old game.
And right there at the start of the game is,
"Try our new basketball game, Tip-Off."
So I'm like, "OK.
We gotta actually have both."
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: And you can show how they're going
from this game, uses all sorts of Android
UI and it's actually kinda ugly, but the game
itself is cool.
So you see, this is not designed at all for
tablets.
You can see all that UI was designed for phones.
And it actually doesn't explain to you how
to play the game at all in the actual game.
But it's essentially exactly the same mechanics--.
>>Ian: So, is that a Box2D net?
>>Dan: It might be.
It's very possible.
I'm not sure.
>>Ian: That's awesome.
>>Dan: But yeah, they've done actually a really
nice job with this game.
And I remember looking at this like, a year
and half or two years ago, whenever it came
out.
I was like, "Wow, nice job."
So, that's cool.
But that's the old version of the game.
And it's actually pretty free of problems
other than ugly, non-tablet UI.
One thing that's very-- when you do it, when
you have something that has been optimized
for tablet, this is what it looks like.
You see, all the buttons are over on the left-hand
side.
They're all really, really small.
And remember, this is an NDPI device.
So, all of your text is gonna be really, really
small because the idea of a tablet is to fit
more stuff on the screen.
And the problem is, in this particular case,
we don't.
What we really want is really nice, big text,
really nice buttons that make sense.
And so, this is, if you don't do any optimization
around tablets, this is what you end up with,
which again is quite playable.
And this game has network challenge and all
sorts of crazy stuff in it.
But I just wanna see more.
You definitely see zoom.
You definitely see the old menu.
Let's go to Tip-Off, which is their new game.
So, which has--.
>>Ian: Clean.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's a completely, this game
is like a completely different kind, different
level of game compared to the original.
It's really cool to see that they went from
that to this.
And it has leader boards, coins.
The only problem is actually from a navigation
perspective.
There's a lot of stuff that are still missing,
especially when you're in the tutorial.
There's a lot of problems.
And so, I kind of, see if we can actually.
So, let's, I think we're not gonna be in this
tutorial level here.
So, you're not going to get to see all the
fun stuff.
You see it's actually the same game with just
a great presentation.
And I think this actually shows what it takes,
what the next level looks like.
I mean, really, this is the exact same game
we saw before with just a ton of other awesomeness
in the presentation.
And I actually, I thought they did such a
good job on this, going from where they were
before.
Now, so here we are.
I hit the back key.
This is not bad, OK?
We're back to copying the dialogue in the
back.
Let's hit the back key again and nothing happens,
OK?
And then, also we have this interesting thing.
There is this, restart and play.
Play, because it looks all different than
all the other options here, I did not even
realize initially that that meant continue
down there at the bottom.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
It doesn't, well, it's weird because it's
actually a different color scheme.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: It almost looks like it's greyed out,
like it's part of a background screen that
isn't active right now.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So I kept hitting restart.
Like, "I'm restarting.
I'm restarting."
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: And that was, again, I did that even
during the tutorial 'cause I couldn't figure
out like, how do I continue?
>>Ian: Yeah.
It's a mismatched style.
>>Dan: It is.
It's a totally mismatched style.
So I definitely wanna see that change.
There's a lot of little tiny UI things here
that actually, that could be altered to make
it better.
I mean, it has a very complete tutorial, which
is slightly annoying because the tutorial
came across as very, very slow unfortunately
in this game.
I don't have it up, so I can't show it to
you.
But I would definitely look at that.
But other than that, this game is looking
really, really good.
A couple of weird back key issues and then
a couple of little UI glitches.
But wow.
Compare those two games and it's night and
day in terms of presentation.
And it shows.
The difference between a game that's good
and a game that is great and is gonna get
featured, a lot of times is just presentation.
This is--.
>>Ian: It really is.
I mean, it's sad to say.
I mean, you'd like to believe that you can
just whip one of these things out in a month
in your garage, but no.
No, you can't.
And as a consumer, that's not what you want,
right?
But if you take some time to do the art right,
yeah, absolutely.
By the way, I'm sorry I seem distracted.
It's just that--.
>>Dan: He's playing games.
>>Ian: I'm playing, well, I'm playing Big
Win Baseball and my team, Reto Likes Sandwiches,
is about to play their first exhibition.
>>Dan: Nice.
And that is true.
So, we can have a Reto-cam right now.
So, the next one we're gonna look at is actually
9 Innings Baseball.
So here we are.
Reto Likes Sandwiches.
>>Ian: Sammiches.
>>Dan: Sammiches.
Is it?
Yeah, exactly.
All right.
So, select control method.
So you got your choice.
You've got auto and semi-auto.
I'm gonna pick auto here.
And no, this is actually--.
>>Ian: 9 Innings?
>>Dan: 9 Innings Baseball, thank you.
Now, we do still see the vestigial menu key
here, which is sad because honestly guys,
it's clear--.
>>Ian: How many times have we talked about
this?
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
It's, it's--.
>>Ian: And I'm not saying like, on this show.
I'm talking about in person that you guys,
guys that made this game.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: It's a Com2uS game, right?
>>Dan: This is a Com2uS game.
>>Ian: Don Lim from Com2uS, dude.
Talk to me.
It's really cool 'cause Com2uS is well-known
for its K-titles, K Baseball, which are like
all these really, really cute little kids
playing baseball, right?
And this is their more realistic title, which
I think appeals to me more.
I think it's more of an American audience
type of title.
>>Dan: Totally.
>>Ian: And I think they've done a pretty good
job.
>>Dan: Yeah, and this actually combines two
different mechanics in the game.
This actually, so the reason why I picked
this game here is that it actually, it actually
combines the arcade mechanic we see here with
this tutorial, which I'm going through really
slowly.
You see, you end up getting cards.
And--.
>>Ian: Who's Emma?
>>Dan: What?
>>Ian: You had an Emma on your screen.
There she is, Emma.
>>Dan: Emma is my tutorial goddess.
>>Ian: Really?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: There's always some cute girl telling
you how to play sports in these games.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Wow.
>>Dan: So there we are.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: And you do see that that was actually
a real--.
>>Ian: Wow.
They're even licensing like--.
>>Dan: Kid characters or something.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Interesting.
Emma doesn't actually know, she doesn't look
like somebody that knows a lot about baseball.
She looks like she's a--.
>>Dan: Oh, she's totally--.
>>Ian: She's on a webcam somewhere, come on.
>>Dan: No.
Emma is totally--.
>>Ian: Like, I'm not being like, sexist here.
It's just that she looks like she's sitting
in her bedroom on a webcam.
>>Dan: Stealing home base, that's hardcore.
>>Ian: You stole home.
>>Dan: I guess.
>>Ian: Nice.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
Don't forget to make your order for the pitcher.
Make his pitch.
All right.
But anyways, the point of this is, let's go
back.
>>Ian: I think they got her off mystockphoto.
I really do.
>>Dan: You think so?
>>Ian: I'm pretty sure, yeah.
>>Dan: All right.
So you actually have cards.
You actually end up with this box of cards
you can manage.
>>Ian: That's cool.
>>Dan: And so, this is actually, it combines
actually a lot of what is going on in an arcade
baseball game.
You can actually buy cards.
You can enhance and mix cards.
And then, you can play the game.
>>Ian: No.
>>Dan: No tutorial.
Back, back.
First of all, on-screen back key.
Ah.
All right.
But at least the back key does actually work,
which is good.
So let's do--.
>>Ian: Yeah, we had this conversation with
a lot of people because they'll say, "Well,
apparently we did some tests and people really
like to have a back key on-screen as well."
Our response is usually, "Well, A, those may
not be your most hardcore Android users.
And B, the whole point is to use a consistent
UI so that we get everybody educated to use
a particular type of UI."
But whatever.
If you don't wanna get featured, go ahead
and put your own on-screen back button in.
[Dan laughs]
Cool.
>>Dan: Exactly.
So, you can see here, actually, what's cool,
you have this combination of only, I've elected
to only play offense 'cause I actually wanna
play defense in the game.
Again, we're in simple mode.
The game has all sorts of different modes
designed to please different kinds of users.
And that's what's actually cool about the
game is it's really, it's just got super deep
modes.
I would say this arcade system is not particularly
deep, but even have two levels of arcade.
This is like the simple arcade and then they
have a complicated arcade.
The one thing they don't have is going all
the way out where Big Win Baseball goes, where
it just allows the game to play itself.
And then, but you, you can go all the way
auto-play through the game like this.
Again, so you can say, "I'm gonna play through
this much of the game and see what happens."
Boom.
So now, it's just doing basic stuff.
You can actually watch it play out.
It's not as, the, again, this is just really,
really simple in terms of presentation when
you're actually watching the game play.
But it gives you that card game mechanics,
which is kinda cool.
And you can see my players are sucking.
None of them are actually scoring.
But you can watch this.
You can even skip this whole thing and just
go right there, back to where I said and just
let the game calculate itself out.
Oh, there we are.
My team's doing pretty well.
So even if all you'd like to do is manage
baseball, you just want to manage the last
couple of innings, you can actually do this.
You can play through the arcade of just the
last couple of innings.
So really--
>>Ian: Oh, cool.
>>Dan: however you wanna play, play baseball,
whether you want the full experience or the
partial experience, this game has it.
I just wanna see--.
>>Ian: That makes sense.
Dan, can I borrow your credit card?
>>Dan: No.
What are you--?
>>Ian: That's OK.
I've actually already got it.
>>Dan: I was gonna say.
>>Ian: We're good.
>>Dan: You're famous.
Actually, you are supporting, by yourself,
Hothead Games, I believe.
>>Ian: Well, my Google self, anyway.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, in any case, I don't want to go too much
farther into this game.
Obviously, the biggest problem with it is
it's just not an Android game.
I mean, it just needs to have the UI slightly
customized for Android.
I definitely wanna see higher resolution art
work, especially in things like the buttons,
which is kind of a shame 'cause you've got
the images.
The images actually scale really, really well
and that's what we've seen, the images scale
really well.
Things like the buttons, we can see these
edges.
It would just be nice.
Give us some hi-res art work.
Give us some higher res fonts and the game
will look just that much better.
So that would be my if I were gonna say anything.
But basically, make sure the back key works
everywhere, man.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: How many times have we said that?
>>Ian: Yeah.
That'll get you nailed.
For the Google Play Store, when they do featuring,
they have a QA process they go to and they're,
the QA people will go through every screen
and try to hit the back key.
>>Dan: And hit the back key.
Yeah.
I'm just like--.
>>Ian: And just dumb stuff like that, right?
'Cause it's really frustrating when it doesn't
work.
>>Dan: Yes.
Exactly.
So, we're actually gonna go contrasting that
to Big Win Baseball.
And Big Win Games are--.
>>Ian: Oh, no.
Let's put it on the phone, actually.
You know, the truth is, this game plays a
lot better on the phone.
>>Dan: Does it really?
>>Ian: But it really does 'cause, because
there's no action.
There's nothing where you have to move your
hands around really fast.
>>Dan: But it looks so pretty.
I like to compare this to, well, I put it
up on--.
>>Ian: Yeah, but you're opening a starter
pack and I'm getting my platinum players going,
right?
>>Dan: No, I just, I wanna show--.
>>Ian: OK.
No, no.
no.
You know what, Dan?
You just do what you want.
>>Dan: No, as soon as the starter pack opens,
I wanna go to yours for play.
But I do wanna show people the contrast, the
presentation.
>>Ian: Right.
Yeah, absolutely.
The presentation of this game is really professional.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Look at that.
All the animation.
>>Dan: You can see that also, all of the fonts
are just beautiful.
They're outlined.
They're actually very close to resolution
as the starter pack itself, it's a little
low there.
But all of the rest, it looks really, really
sharp.
And it just makes a huge difference when you're
on a tablet like this.
And as you can see it's, from a tablet perspective,
they're doing a pretty, pretty good job.
They're actually using the keyboard, which
isn't bad.
>>Ian: Let's make that Whiskey Rebels.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, go ahead.
You've got the keyboard now.
>>Dan: Right, exactly.
Oh.
>>Ian: Oh, are you gonna spell whiskey with
an "e?"
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Is that the kind of whiskey you like?
[Dan laughs]
Big Pete begs to differ.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
>>Ian: All right, then.
Fine.
>>Dan: We're American whiskey, here.
>>Ian: I think you mean 'murican.
>>Dan: 'murican whiskey.
All right.
So we get to select cards.
Any suggestions here?
>>Ian: Oh, you know what?
It just makes you use all three of them.
>>Dan: Yeah.
That's a good point.
It does.
>>Ian: So the only thing I don't like about
Big Win Baseball, compared to, let's say,
Big Win Hockey, which I went nuts over, too
many players.
You have ten players to manage.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Starting lineup for hockey is five players.
It's a lot easier to fill them all with platinum.
It's a lot easier to remember who they are.
This is a lot.
But--.
>>Dan: Well, baseball in general is a complicated
game to manage.
I think it's--.
>>Ian: I mean, when I think about baseball,
I mostly think of where's the garlic fries?
So, I'm probably not the target audience.
>>Dan: Yeah.
But the garlic fries are really, really good.
Although, they're actually--.
>>Ian: Although, I did just spend like ten
bucks on big boosters.
>>Dan: Yeah, and they are right in the little
Gordon Biersch Stand, right on the left hand
side of--.
>>Ian: Anyway.
>>Dan: [inaudible].
>>Ian: I haven't been to a baseball game since
I lived in Seattle, actually.
>>Dan: Oh, really?
>>Ian: No.
>>Dan: No, we need to get you to a game.
>>Ian: There you go.
>>Dan: So, yeah.
Again, the presentation is really what they
have done an incredible job with in this game.
>>Ian: Yeah, but as you know, earlier on in
my career, I did sports games for Microsoft.
And I remember that was something we spent
a long time on.
You try to make things look like a network
broadcast.
All of this presentation is just really, really
good, especially for such a small game.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: The camera motions, the animation,
the sliding in and out, the crispness of the
graphics, it's all just really, really high
quality.
>>Dan: It's well done.
It's very well done for what it is.
I mean, it's not like a full-blown, 3D baseball
like we've seen, but for what they're doing
with 2D with a little bit of transformation,
it's quite good.
And again, this is just a card game.
But for people who really like to manage baseball,
it gets a little closer to that.
It's not a realistic game in any sense.
It really is a card game that has baseball
stuff thrown into it.
>>Ian: Well, what's really fun about this,
so we're watching a game right now.
And the truth is, what we're really watching
is a computer simulation, the outcome of which
is known as soon as it starts.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: But the fun thing about watching it
is first, it is fun.
They do some nice things with the graphics.
They, but more than anything else, they show
you what your players can and can't do and
where they screw up.
>>Dan: I have a beer in my hand and I'm watching
the tablet play baseball.
This is like, this is fun right here.
>>Ian: Yeah, this is awesome.
>>Dan: Yeah, I know.
All right.
>>Ian: Let's switch to camera two.
>>Dan: I know.
Really?
>>Ian: Come on.
>>Dan: It spilled all over my EA shirt.
>>Ian: Drinking problem.
>>Dan: I know.
True.
>>Ian: All right.
So anyway.
We can skip this.
You can skip it at any time.
The value of watching it is so you get to
see where your team members are screwing up.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: OK.
So, I'm gonna keep kicking people's ass at
Big Win Baseball.
>>Dan: I'm gonna continue with the other game.
>>Ian: You bet.
>>Dan: All right.
So, in general, this game also has occasional
issues with back key, mostly where they couldn't
figure out what it would do.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: And again, figure out what it will
do.
Make it do something.
All right.
Let's go into comedy here.
I'm gonna have to rotate the screen on this
one.
>>Ian: We're doing comedy games?
>>Dan: This is--.
>>Ian: Nice.
>>Dan: This is, this is, it is a sort of a
sports game.
This is the Neymar game.
>>Ian: This is a fantasy game.
>>Dan: Yeah.
And your goal is--.
>>Ian: That's who I wanna be right there,
that guy.
>>Dan: The goal is to keep it, oh.
Are we not getting output?
There we are.
Now you guys are seeing it.
Oh yeah.
>>Ian: No, they're not seeing it.
Oh, now they are.
OK.
>>Dan: Now they're seeing it.
That's what I mean.
Oh yeah.
>>Ian: This is great.
This totally reminds me of like, arcade games
from 1985.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: Right when they first got video into
them.
>>Dan: This is, oh, sorry.
It's the Neymar game.
How do you pronounce the game?
Someone's got to know.
>>Ian: Don't you recognize Neymar?
>>Dan: He's only the football hero.
>>Ian: I don't know who this guy is.
>>Dan: He is the number one footballer of
just basically in the world today.
>>Reto: We call that soccer here in the United
States, right?
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: Right.
>>Ian: Yeah, here in the United States.
Sure.
Yeah.
>>Dan: Hey, women's soccer just won the gold
for the US.
And it was kick ass, by the way.
You saw those matches.
Both against UK and Japan.
It was, they were really amazing.
Those are some seriously tough women, I'll
have to say.
And they did an amazing job.
So anyways, your job is to keep the ball alive.
I wouldn't really call it a soccer game.
I wouldn't really call it a sports game.
It is sports related and it's kind of fun.
>>Ian: Of course it's a sport.
>>Dan: It has like, seven animations.
>>Ian: Sure, you're doing it with a soccer
ball, but you could be doing it with a hackey
sack and then it would be the national sport
of all like, old people in China.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: All right, let's go on.
>>Ian: That was cool.
>>Dan: It's totally fine.
>>Ian: I would play that.
>>Dan: The biggest problem with this game,
and I'll show you it, is it actually uses
a permission which I really hate people using,
which is prevent system lock.
So now, I hit the back button again and boom,
I'm back in the game without a lock.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
That's a little annoying because you'd think
that when you clear the screen, especially
somebody like you, Dan, where you will frequently
play games in the middle of conducting high-level
secret conversations.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: You have the nuclear launch codes on
your laptop.
You have the code to Sergei's Batman lair.
We don't want those things stolen.
>>Dan: No, absolutely.
And besides, we all know that Larry is Batman.
Let's be, Sergei's too obvious.
He makes, he's more like Alfred.
He makes the toys.
>>Ian: You do realize that that was a secret,
right?
There's like this misdirect thing going on.
And now you've just like, everybody on--.
You know what?
We're gonna get kicked off YouTube.
>>Dan: Oh, sorry.
You know what?
I mean, you probably just, all you have to
do is hear Larry talk these days, you know
you know.
>>Ian: Hey, I'm Batman.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Reto: OK, keep this up and I'm cutting you
guys off.
>>Ian: All right.
All right.
>>Dan: That's right.
Wait.
Are we really being cut off?
>>Ian: No.
>>Dan: So--.
>>Ian: Daniel just needs to go to the bathroom
again.
All right.
So, this is a good game, but it shouldn't
ask for that permission.
That's dumb.
Don't do that.
>>Dan: Yeah.
And also, the game continues to play underneath
the lock screen when you lock it.
>>Ian: What the hell?
>>Dan: We couldn't figure out how to stop
it, so we just did, we're not gonna allow
you to lock it.
No.
Don't do that.
That sucks.
Oh, my God.
Bad.
>>Ian: Oh, I just, so guys.
I wanna go on record in saying, and I'll just
hold this up.
Actually, can you put the device cam on the
phone cam?
Yeah.
What does that say, Dan?
>>Dan: It's five point five percent alcohol
by volume.
>>Ian: And how much is left?
>>Dan: About two-thirds of a bottle.
>>Ian: I rest my case.
Next game.
>>Dan: Are you saying that I've been doing
more of the talking?
>>Ian: No, no.
You're supposed to do more of the talking.
>>Dan: OK.
The next one is Toons 2012 Summer Games, which
displays that--.
>>Ian: Can you say 2012?
Is that OK?
>>Dan: I think so.
>>Ian: Are you sure?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: And games?
>>Dan: Oh, that's a good question.
>>Ian: I think there's some jack booted thugs
out there that wanna--.
OK.
Let's, moving right along.
So, let's see this thing.
>>Dan: All right.
So, 2012--.
>>Ian: Oh, dude.
Is this like that old Hannah Barbara cartoon?
>>Dan: This--.
>>Ian: Come on Mugsy, we need to cheat.
>>Dan: I really loved this game, I hate to
say.
>>Ian: It's all right.
I love Summer Games.
It's great.
>>Dan: My, the sad--.
>>Ian: Not as good as Winter Games, but--.
>>Dan: The sad points about this game.
One, is that world challenge rather than actually
opening up a web view inside of the game,
actually opens up a web view outside of the
game.
>>Ian: We could debate endlessly which is
worse, but the point is they open up a web
view.
Come on.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's sad.
But any case.
So, anyways, you've got, we can go through
here and we've got on-screen back buttons.
>>Ian: You know what opening up a web view
says, by the way?
I'm just gonna say this and I know this is
gonna be a little bit politically incorrect.
But opening up a web view basically says,
"We wanna cheat people on our payroll."
Right?
I mean, come on.
You're like Java Script programmers.
You gotta do that stuff?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Let's do it native, come on.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
So, here we are.
We have an on-screen back button and we have
no support for the back key.
>>Ian: No good.
No.
Yeah, right there.
>>Dan: They're at least targeting SDK, version
11 or higher or whatever 'cause we've gotten
rid of all of the menu key.
This is the menu key, which is good.
That's a good start.
And--.
>>Ian: Let's see the game, actually.
You know what?
People are bored with us--.
>>Dan: Harping on the menu key, back key,
over and over again.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: But they keep coming and stuff.
And you know what that's like?
So sad.
>>Ian: You get an email saying, "Hey, we didn't
actually feature you and here's why."
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: It's tough.
>>Dan: I actually played the boxing game before,
so let's do it.
All right.
Here we are.
And everything has this--.
>>Ian: This is cute.
>>Dan: This is totally cute.
As I said, the whole game is cute.
Defend.
OK.
Defend and--.
>>Ian: Wow.
It's like Punch Out, but with turtles.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
So, how do I attack?
There we are.
Hit.
Ooh, I like that.
>>Ian: You like punching turtles?
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: You're a turtle puncher?
>>Dan: He's a snapping turtle.
OK.
I'm totally this.
Oh, man.
>>Ian: I ate a turtle once and it was the
saddest thing ever 'cause they brought it
out with like this little shell on it and
everything.
And he looked so cute.
>>Dan: Yeah.
I remember going to the markets in Taipei
and actually seeing partially, recently, oh
man.
I just totally died.
>>Ian: All right.
Let's see another sport.
That one sucked.
>>Dan: It looked good, though.
Didn't it?
>>Ian: The back button doesn't work.
>>Dan: The back button doesn't work anywhere
in this game.
I just hit the home key.
>>Ian: Oh, wow.
>>Dan: You get to see what happens now.
Let's go back.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: Toon Summer Games.
>>Ian: And--.
>>Dan: Come on.
Do it.
Yeah.
All right.
>>Ian: BMX?
Wait, is BMX a summer game?
>>Dan: It is in their summer games.
All right.
>>Ian: Can we play dressage?
>>Dan: [laughs] No, I don't think they have
dressage.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: Oh, wow.
Awesome.
I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing.
>>Ian: Seriously, this is just like those
cartoons we used to watch when we were kids.
They were like Manilla Gorilla or whatever
he was.
>>Dan: Totally.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
>>Dan: This is one of the, oh.
Sorry.
See, every time I pick up the tablet, we lose
HDMI.
Oh.
>>Ian: Oh, that hurts.
>>Dan: That did.
Totally hurt.
>>Ian: That is a really small bike.
>>Dan: [laughs] Anyways.
I really do love this game.
I want them to fix their back key issues.
I wish we could feature them tomorrow.
I mean, to be honest, I'm sure it's--.
Unfortunately, by the time they fix everything
in it, the games are gonna be over.
>>Ian: What I love is the way that this gorilla
riding a BMX bike on these random sandy hills
is also doing it in front of a backdrop of
the London skyline.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Look, it's the Gherkin.
>>Dan: [laughs] Exactly.
Look, it's the London Eye.
>>Reto: Have you not been to London recently,
Ian?
You haven't seen the Great Sand Dunes of South
London?
>>Ian: No, I've not, but then again, I never
did go to South London.
>>Dan: There you go.
>>Reto: You're missing out.
>>Dan: Actually, what we're just doing is
we're down in what like, in like Sussex or
something like that, right?
>>Ian: Absolutely.
So, here's my real question, Reto.
Are you checking for people that are asking
us questions or berating us or calling me
a racist on live stream?
Or, are you checking Meme Gen?
>>Reto: I'm reading memes and eating a sandwich.
[Dan laughs]
>>Ian: Sure.
How's that sandwich?
>>Reto: It's fantastic.
>>Dan: Yeah.
The sandwiches here are great.
>>Ian: I'm really glad you brought enough
for the whole class.
>>Reto: Of course.
>>Dan: [unintelligible].
>>Ian: Not after eating two psycho donuts
for breakfast.
>>Reto: Breakfast of champions.
>>Ian: Indeed.
>>Dan: I bet this is how you get, there we
are.
>>Ian: Wait.
You're--.
>>Dan: I'm trying to lift.
I'm trying to lift.
There we are.
>>Ian: This is, you can't actually see what
Dan is doing with his hands, but it's curious.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
Nice.
>>Dan: No, wait.
Ah.
It's all over.
Yes.
Finished.
No.
I lost.
I died.
What a pity.
Objective breached.
>>Ian: All right.
So, what else do we have to look at today?
>>Dan: All right.
So, I love that game.
We have, the last one is Blobby Volleyball.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: And once again, presentation-wise,
there's a lot of tack in this game.
And there's just--.
>>Ian: Tack?
>>Dan: Tech.
There's a lot of tech in this game.
But there just needs to be a lot of work in
the presentation.
There's nothing worse than having this old
school font than having this old school font
with this outline, which shows how low res
everything is.
>>Ian: Well, it could be, I mean, it could
be an homage.
It feels like Lucas Arts in 1989.
>>Dan: Yeah.
All right.
We're gonna play against bots.
This game really does shine, though, with
its two-player mode as far as I can tell.
>>Ian: Oh, that's cool.
>>Dan: And yeah.
And actually, the game itself is really well
done.
>>Ian: It's like the ultimate distillation
of Dead or Alive beach volleyball.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It kind of is.
Wait.
But no one would've like Dead or Alive beach
volleyball if it didn't have girls in bikinis,
right?
Isn't that--?
>>Ian: I think they've captured the essence
of it.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: I'm sure someone would have.
Actually, one of my friends loved Dead or
Alive.
Also, I do like the fact that you're actually--.
>>Ian: My wife loved beach volleyball.
To my enduring puzzlement.
>>Dan: Also, you can hit the ball a lot.
Yes.
I finally won a point.
>>Ian: This is really, by the way, we're,
if you'd like to help out with our show, we're
looking for a replacement for Dan, who can
play games.
>>Dan: Yeah.
That's basically what it comes down to.
[laughs]
>>Ian: All right.
So tell us about the game.
What are they doing right?
>>Dan: So, what they're doing right is they
actually have reasonable back key mode.
And the game actually, the presentation actually,
when you actually get into the game itself,
it's pretty good.
What they need to do is obviously focus on
getting presentation everywhere to that level.
And it's funny.
It's that 90 percent thing.
I think they've actually done, they have support
for wi-fi.
It's like, it would be great if the wi-fi
stuff would feel a little less technical,
but it's cool Bluetooth.
They actually have it too--.
>>Ian: It does take you back, though.
It takes to back to when you'd actually build
like an IPX, SPX LAN from scratch.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Just to play Doom.
>>Dan: Totally, totally.
And honestly, the final thing is just the
general presentation of the game.
It just needs to be just that much sharper
and that much better.
>>Ian: Right.
It needs polish.
>>Dan: It needs polish.
But it looks--.
>>Ian: Well, it's interesting because you
contrast this with something like Big Win
Baseball and the truth is, I'm not, I don't
want to make a value judgment about which
game is better, which game is more fun.
But let's just talk about the packaging.
The way that people feel when they're playing
the game.
It's like you can have two cars that are equally
fast, equally as fun to drive.
But one's all like rusted out and the paint's
all pitted and everything.
And one's painted really nicely.
It just, it makes you feel psychologically
different.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So we can turn off the basketball, the Blobby
Volleyball card here.
And I really liked, the example is this.
This is, if you turn off the Blobby Volleyball
card right now, Daniel.
'Cause they're not on it anymore.
>>Ian: Do you see what happened?
Do you see what happens?
One week, first week, always just right on
the ball, totally on the ball.
Second week, just like, "Screw you guys."
>>Dan: Dan's talking.
There's a basketball--.
>>Ian: Whatever.
And then I'm like watching something, yeah.
How are the young and the restless?
>>Dan: Oh.
>>Ian: Because--.
>>Dan: No, no.
He's looking at me and Jen.
So, let's be serious.
>>Ian: All right.
Yeah.
I love soap operas.
>>Dan: Oh, yes.
So, so here we are.
So just by comparison, this is Tip-Off here.
I'm sorry, this is Basketball Lite here.
And contrast that to what they've done in
their new game in terms of Tip-Off.
And it's just--.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: Yes, this had a lot of loading screens,
but other than that,--.
>>Ian: It hardly, I feel like a lot of it
is just going in and getting a designer to
work on the game for about five days or less
is all it would take.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
They've done a lot here.
Let's--.
>>Ian: No, no.
I realize the implementation took longer.
I'm saying like, if you or I was to go in
with a game, a crummy game that we did and
take it to Roman Nurik, for instance.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Roman Nurik, the Ukranian.
>>Dan: Yeah, and have him hire an artist.
>>Ian: No.
I mean, he would like photoshop some mocks
for us.
And then, we could implement them and they
would look good instead of bad, the way most
of our games look.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Especially my games.
So, in any case, yeah.
The, so that's just an example of a developer
who took an initial game concept, which was
really great, and took it to the next level
with this really cool, polished UI.
And again, that's the kind of thing that needs
to happen with Blobby Volleyball.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan: It's really good.
And it just needs to be taken to that next
level.
>>Ian: Yeah.
And you can tell, right?
You can tell if you're not at that level.
And if you can't?
Hire somebody who can.
It's not the kind of talent everybody has.
>>Dan: Exactly.
And my feeling is people say, "What does it
take to get featured?"
And I say, "Well, it takes a great game that
has a good presentation."
At least a good presentation.
It doesn't have to be a spectacular presentation,
but you have to remember.
Your game has to be at that level, off the
screen here, if it doesn't have that presentation.
Like, it has to be so good.
It has to be a concept that's so amazing,
have never seen anything like it, that's got
rave reviews and that kind of thing.
The presentation is really important.
>>Ian: Yeah, 'cause remember, this reflects
on us, right?
The Google Play Team looks at a game.
Says, "OK, we're gonna maybe have a screen
shot.
We're gonna have a feature graphic."
The quality of that presentation is going
to reflect directly on Google Play.
And they're going to be asking themselves,
"Is today's set of games going to make Google
Play look like a champion, or is it gonna
make it look like the cigarettes and pure
water store across from my house, right next
to the porn dealership and the check cashing
place?"
>>Dan: You're house is in the most awesome
location.
Let me just say that.
So,--.
>>Ian: Just think about that is all I'm saying.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, what you're looking at is--.
>>Ian: What are we looking at?
>>Dan: Wow.
All right.
I'm not even gonna, I'm not gonna put that
up.
So,--.
>>Ian: Was it dirty?
>>Dan: No.
It said, so in there, in Blobby Volleyball,
they had me look at this.
But in Blobby Volleyball, there's a copy.
They mention that they're using the Paypal
library tool with ad blocking.
So, yes.
Exactly.
>>Ian: Wait.
Hang on.
I'm trying to--.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: What?
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: Put that up again.
>>Dan: Nice.
>>Ian: We're gonna do a special segment on
this.
Special 30-second investigative segment on
what are they doing?
>>Dan: We added a paid feature for blocking
ads.
We need to add permission to read [inaudible]
and identity used by Paypal library to allow
in-app payments and ad blocking.
First of all, you're not allowed to use Paypal
to do this.
>>Ian: Yeah.
So you guys, by the time you go to look at
Blobby Volleyball, it may not be there anymore.
>>Dan: It's very possible.
>>Ian: Yeah.
That violates Google policy.
>>Dan: Our policy, yeah.
And actually, we recently updated the policy
to really clarify this to make it very, 'cause
a lot of developers will read through the
policy and they wouldn't understand it.
So now, it's very clear in the policy.
So, yeah dudes.
Switch to using in-app payments on Google
Play if you're gonna list the game on Google
Play.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: It's just that simple.
>>Ian: Everyone has to use in-app payments.
There are a couple of small exceptions.
They don't apply to you.
I guarantee it.
They do not.
>>Dan: No, they do not.
>>Ian: So, use Google Play payments.
>>Dan: So, and the real key thing is, again,
when someone's looking at the game, first
of all, putting OpenFeint pictures in your
game.
I mean, that does not make me want to go and
download the game right there at all.
It makes me actually not want to download
the game.
>>Ian: No, especially the thing with the,
their list of what are those?
Oh, I thought that was like their tap joy
list or something, or an offer wall.
>>Dan: No, no.
That's just how bad achievements look in OpenFeint.
>>Ian: The only, and ironically, there is
one screen that looks great here.
And it's the end game screen.
It's not a bad game.
>>Dan: It is.
It isn't.
And actually, what's funny is the font, weirdly
enough, looks better in their screen shots
than it does in the game that I have.
I'm not sure--.
>>Ian: That screen shot is reduced.
>>Dan: No, no.
It's actually, as I look it's a different
font style.
>>Ian: Really?
>>Dan: Yeah.
That font, see it's a larger, wider serif
on the font.
>>Ian: We could talk about this for days and
days.
Let's go ahead and call a moratorium here.
Call an end to this show.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: But we've looked at some great sport's
games.
>>Dan: Wait, have we?
Oh, yes, we have.
>>Ian: We have.
And a lot of games that we did not know about.
I mean, we've seen the Madden's.
We've seen the--.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Those are fun games, but it was really
cool to see some smaller Indie titles, especially
that Tip-Off basketball, how they improved.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: I think every developer can learn from
that story.
>>Dan: I want you to, I was really personally
excited about Ninja Volley.
I really wanna see where that team goes with
that.
I think that--.
>>Ian: That's a good idea.
>>Dan: It's a really good idea and it's really
cute.
And I was also personally, Tip-Off is great.
Star Dunk was really fun.
Again, I like games that have competitive
aspects to it.
And it was just awesome.
I did not know about the Toons Summer Games
game.
And I totally wanna see them just--.
>>Ian: That was really cute.
>>Dan: It was totally cute.
I wanna see them clean it up.
I'm really sad that I didn't find out about
that a month ago.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: To be honest because I would've said,
"All right.
Do this and this and this and this and then--."
>>Ian: Well, yeah.
We would've featured it for the Olympics.
Totally.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
We would absolutely feature it.
It's hard.
I mean, the team here doesn't catch everything
that goes through.
And so, that's part of the reason we do this
show.
And so, I wish we would have done sports last
week, but we had a lot of fun with racing
last week.
And what's our next week's show?
>>Ian: Next week's show is ARPGs.
>>Dan: That's right.
That's right.
We're going to, A. What does A mean?
>>Ian: J or K?
>>Dan: Oh, OK, OK.
That's right.
That's not a joke.
So, we're talking about--.
>>Ian: Japanese role-playing games, Korean
role-playing games.
Really, any Pacific rim role-playing games.
You know what we're talking about--the genre.
>>Dan: PRRPG.
>>Ian: You can totally, yeah.
It's not it.
I mean, you don't have to be Asian to make
them, but--.
>>Dan: Yes, exactly.
>>Ian: It doesn't hurt.
So then--.
>>Dan: Anachronox is in that model in some
ways.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: I mean, it was still one of my favorites.
>>Ian: Yeah.
So, the yeah.
The cutesy, PlayStation portable type of role-playing
games.
There's a ton of them out there.
A lot of them come from like, Com2uS always
puts one out every few months, Gameville.
>>Dan: By the way, I totally want to see a
mobile version of Anachronox, even though
I know no one useful has the rights to that
license.
>>Ian: I want to see that Mickey game, what
is that called?
Kingdom Hearts.
>>Dan: Oh, Kingdom Hearts is awesome.
>>Ian: That was so cool.
So, yeah.
If you guys know of some great Asian role-playing
games, we totally wanna see them.
Dan here is a huge fan and I nod along and
pretend that I understand what's happening.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: So we'll totally go over that next
week.
And we will see you on the flip side.
>>Dan: I just wanna point this out, that this
is almost gone, by the way.
It's almost gone, see?
Yeah.
>>Ian: That explains so much.
All right.
I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
This is Dan Galpin.
Fred, no, I'm sorry.
Fred Chung was nowhere to be found.
Reto Meier was our producer.
Daniel Phang was our engineer.
And we are out of here.
>>Dan: Cheers.
[clink]
That bottle was empty.